So can I ask you to sit down?
Martin, you are a consultant head and neck
surgeon at UCLH,
and you Francesca are a soprano singer
from the Royal Opera House Jette Parker Young
Artists Programme.
And what we are going to do is use this rather
alarmingly large piece of equipment
to have a look at a larynx in action, I understand.
We are.
- OK, so what actually is this?
So this is equipment we use in the clinic
in the hospitals every day.
And it's a nasal endoscopy stack,
and we use it for looking at the throat and
diagnosing people.
Can we actually do that now?
- Absolutely we can.
Are you ready for this?
- Yes.
What's the actual device like?
What we've got here is, it has three bits
to this.
We got a light source here.
We've got a processor.
And we've got a strobe light generator.
This itself is the endoscope.
In the old days these used to have, they were
fibre optics,
and so you'd get an image that was made up
like the eye of an insect.
Nowadays we are fortunate enough to have very
high definition cameras.
Much better than the ones in your phones.
Right on the end so we can see right inside.
OK, so can we do that now?
Is that alright with you?
So we're going to drop the endoscope down
actually to look right at Francesca's larynx.
That's precisely what we are going to do.
You'll be able to see the image on the screen
here.
OK, thank you very much.
Just breathe gently through your nose.
Relax your shoulders.
This is going to tickle a little bit.
Could I see the screen, Idris?
Thank you very much.
Is that the back of the nose?
No, we're actually going through the nose
at the moment.
The nose is very important for the voice actually.
It's an air conditioning device.
It warms, humidifies, filters the air that
we breathe
to make sure that everything that we breathe
in is nice and clean.
That's why it's bad to breathe through your
mouth.
And that's the larynx?
- It is.
So what we are looking at there is a very
alien looking thing, isn't it?
It's the larynx in the middle of the view
there.
The vocal cords are the two grey things moving
in and out, forming a V-shape in the centre.
The big floppy thing is called the epiglottis.
It's like a trap door.
It stops food and drink going down the wrong
way.
And the two round things towards the back
are called aritenoides.
They are bones that move the vocal cords in
and out.
Francesca, would you feel OK to sing a note
for us?
- OK.
Any note? Just go for it?
-Absolutely.
[Sings note]
I could hear and I could see that the larynx
came together, but I couldn't see the moving.
You'll see it now. We've now switched to a different light source.
It's going to flash light out of phase with
the
fundamental frequency of the sound that she
makes.
Basically strobing like in discos, when I
was a young man a long time ago,
it slows down movement. You should see this
here.
So if you'd like to make a slightly higher
frequency sound, Francesca.
[Sings high pitched note]
Very good.
- Fantastic.
I could feel that.
- Very well done.
Could you do a glissando for us? From as
low as you can to as high as you can?
This feels so weird.
[Sings a glissando]
Beautiful, so you can see the vocal cords lengthening
and shortening.
[Applause]